this is your tech news briefing for
thursday september 8th i'm zoe thomas
for the wall street journal
apple is sometimes accused of creating a
walled garden an ecosystem that's
beautiful but locks users into it
for its part apple says it makes systems
that customers want to use and that
integrate well with other products and
services it offers
that was the pitch from ceo tim cook at
the company's big annual event on
wednesday where it revealed new iphones
a new apple smart watch and updated
airpod headphones
they're always with you useful wherever
and whenever you need them and are
designed to work seamlessly together
on their own each is industry leading
together they provide a magical
experience
to help convince users of their magic
apple also made a surprise move it's
keeping prices steady
joining us to discuss the company's
approach and the new features it's
bringing to its products is our personal
tech bureau chief wilson rothman hi
wilson hey zoe how are you i'm great so
this is the event where apple unveils
its new line of iphones what do we get
with the new iphone 14 well i think that
one of the big things they did was they
brought back a very popular phone from
about five years ago that plus sized
phone that so many people had the seven
plus or the eight plus and then they
kind of did away with that nice value it
was like a big screen but for a decent
price
so what you have now is the 14 plus
which is an 899 phone
that has kind of the lower specs of the
14
but the bigger screen of those pro max
phones that have cost 1100 bucks all
right so let's talk about some of the
differences here because if you were you
know trolling social media as i was
during the event you saw a lot of people
comparing the iphone 14 to
previous generations of iphones so what
is different in these new models yeah
you know the lower two of the iphone 14s
really do resemble the previous phones
in a lot of ways so i don't disagree
with people who say they're almost
indistinguishable except for that one
big size bump because the 13 had a mini
we don't have a mini anymore so that
breaks the heart of some people but
sales wise that's not as big a thing so
the bigger size is what apple was going
for on the iphone 14. now the iphone 14
pro has a lot of new things that are
different and new one of the biggest is
that the camera the top camera in there
is now 48 megapixels that's up from 12.
so it's a big jump for apple that's
always kind of played down the megapixel
game suddenly they have this gigantic
camera in there another important thing
about the iphone 14 pro is that it has
an always on display this is something
that competitors like the samsung phones
have had where basically the screen dims
and you just see the really important
stuff like you know certain widgets or
notifications and then the time you
don't have to like reach over and tap
your phone but it slows down the refresh
rate so that it's not draining the
battery normally the phone can refresh
at like 60 times a second this makes it
refresh only around one time per second
let's talk about the other products that
apple brought out on wednesday because
it wasn't just about the phone and tim
cook kind of made a big deal of this at
the beginning saying it's all about
these products integrating together so
one of the things that they have is a
new version of the apple watch can you
tell us briefly what's new here one of
the the really cool things they added
was a thermometer that can help with uh
there's an ovulation app and a period
tracker that's already in the apple
health kind of stack of programs and
this thermometer will help with that
will give additional useful information
for women who are tracking their periods
in ovulation
another feature that's new to the
regular apple watch is crash detection
where it uses motion sensors inside to
determine whether you've been in
several different types of car accidents
including rolling over and getting hit
on the side but the big news was a big
big big watch
it's gonna look chunky on some people
but it is something that a lot of you
know extreme athletes and people who do
things even like i do i'm not an extreme
athlete but i love diving the new apple
watch ultra it's 800 bucks but it has
all these features that we haven't seen
before it is as i mentioned diving it is
a dive computer it can go down i think
around 130 feet it's extremely rugged
it's got a 36 hour battery and it's got
an optimized battery setting so it can
actually go even longer up to 60 hours
so it's a monster of a watch but it's
kind of what everyone's been waiting for
because
on that high end apple hasn't really
been able to compete with garmin which
is kind of the big time athlete's watch
of choice
the other thing they brought out is a
new generation of their headphones did
much change there
so you know they look the same
they have longer battery life out of the
box so it's a six hour battery life i
think that's a 20 30 percent improvement
it's really it's going to be noticeable
for people the case you know charging
case together provides up to 30 hours of
battery life which is really nice and
they've also improved the noise
cancellation as you might know there's a
transparency mode we call it the don't
get hit by a bus mode like you're
crossing the street you hear a honk you
look up you know if you have full noise
cancelling on you won't hear that honk
but if you push it into transparency
mode you will so now they have something
called adaptive transparency mode which
i think has more like it's using more of
the sensors that make noise canceling
work
but it's doing more to like kind of
figure out maybe make it even easier to
hear that bus coming or that hear that
honking of a horn you know overall
smartphone sales are down for the
industry people have been pulling back
on buying expensive tech gadgets
altogether and apple has seemed to you
know defy that trend but it did decide
not to raise prices on iphone models
what does this tell us about apple's
strategy i think that shows a conscious
decision on the bean counters at apple
on their part to like
not shock people with price maybe this
inflation thing is scaring enough people
and suddenly you hear oh the price isn't
going up on this
wow that's great news it's almost like a
discount in an inflationary environment
i mean that i do think that's a
calculation a marketing calculation that
they're making a bet that they're going
to sell more because of that to offset
whatever cost they're eating by not
raising the price
the other thing is
that the premium tier
of smartphones the 900 and up have
actually not
experienced any sales depression the way
these lower end phones have
overall you find people are willing to
hold on to their phones longer
but the people spending less money on
their phones are actually more likely to
hold on to them longer because they
don't care
people like me i'm a nerd i like my
phones you know i spent a thousand
dollars on it you know last year i'm
probably gonna sit out this year but you
bet next year i'm gonna buy a new phone
i think it's justifiable for people who
are you know have a lot going on in
their phones that they want to have
something that works and keeps up with
the times
but it is true that there's a certain
sales bracket that actually hasn't had a
decline and that's where apple plays
mostly in that sandbox
all right that's our personal tech
editor wilson rothman thanks for joining
us wilson it's my pleasure though
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing
for more tech stories check out our
website wsj.com i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]
you